[Applause]
[Music]
this is warsaw in poland where thousands
of people have been protesting against a
near total ban on abortion
a strike is underway and major roads and
bridges have been blocked across the
country
scuffles have erupted in parliament with
opposition mps
carrying signs that say this is war
here's why the ruling has caused such
anger and why unrest there
matters
before a new high court ruling poland's
abortion laws
were already amongst the strictest in
europe abortions were only permitted in
the case of a fetal abnormality
rape incest or to protect the mother's
life
and doctors in poland can refuse to
perform legal abortions
many do so on religious grounds this has
forced thousands of women to seek
terminations abroad
or to have to risk illegal abortions i
was
like really really scared because i
didn't have money to go
up to go to abroad and i knew that there
is no other possibility for me to have
a person in medical clinic
but in october 2020 poland's top court
ruled abortion on the basis of a fetal
abnormality
is unconstitutional the overwhelming
majority of legal abortions performed in
poland
are due to fetal abnormalities so some
see this new rule
as an almost total ban women in in
poland will not be able to abort
uh pregnancies that threaten their lives
or that will
give birth to babies that will die soon
after birth in in awful pain and this is
against human rights against
women's rights and as young women we
feel that it is our obligation to stand
here today
to protest this this oppressive regime
that we have in poland
this red lightning image has become a
symbol of the protests that have
occupied several major cities
across the country and despite poland
being one of europe's most staunchly
roman catholic countries
reports suggest that the vast majority
of people are against making abortion
laws stricter
the ruling law and justice party has
effectively abolished legal abortion
without a parliamentary bill debate or
public consultation
we reject the notion that there is human
right to abortion there is
no such thing in international law there
are attempts at establishing it but
nobody ever agreed to that and this
is simply wrong this is simply
unacceptable
it's not the first time lawmakers in
poland have tried to impose a total ban
on abortion
in 2016 a similar attempt prompted black
marches
where hundreds of thousands of women
turned out in the rain to protest
forcing the government to back down
in a symbolic way this country
says us that we are nothing you know
we are not important we have to stay at
home
uh give birth and you know
do the family and care work what makes
these protests different
is that demonstrators have challenged
the authority of the church for the
first time
since the collapse of communism in 1989
the church has held
enormous influence the government
presents itself as the defender of
traditional catholic values
and has pushed back against liberal
western ideas
but now church services all over poland
have been disrupted
and priests have been confronted and
some see this as a tipping point for the
church's authority
i think there is certainly there are
certainly some groups of radical left
unfortunately they are gaining a lot of
support in
in the media recently that they are
trying to
incentivize uh yeah especially younger
people to
find a common enemy in churches of
course the very
comfortable enemy so to say but this is
very dangerous approach
we are open to to talk we're open to to
discuss the debates
uh but the civility must be
what remains to be seen is whether the
government will back down
over the issue i believe
that this is the beginning of
irish situation maybe
in you know five years we're gonna have
changes
like in ireland two years ago
the the biggest reality of abortion is
that people will always have abortion
and they will find a way
to do it